Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. ivy stevens had been looking forward to the 13th of july for weeks she and her husband had planned their big night out long in advance and as it approached it was hard not to be excited it had been a dreadfully muggy oppressive day with temperatures heading well into the 90s and manhattan's crowded streets sweltered with noise and sweat and heat. It was still dreadfully hot and humid that evening, and it was a relief, therefore, for Ivy to walk into the air-conditioned light and coolness of the World Trade Center,
感谢您收听《历史余韵》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。艾薇·史蒂文斯（Ivy Stevens）已经盼望7月13日这一天好几周了。她和丈夫很早就计划好了那个盛大的夜晚，随着日子临近，她很难不感到兴奋。那天天气闷热得可怕，气温直逼90华氏度（约32摄氏度），曼哈顿拥挤的街道上充斥着噪音、汗水和热浪。那天晚上依然闷热潮湿，因此，当艾薇走进世界贸易中心那灯火通明、凉爽宜人的空调房时，她感到如释重负。
its gleaming towers still only a few years old, and ride the elevator 107 floors up to Windows on the World, the elegant restaurant that looked out across the city. And of course, the evening was every bit as exceptional and memorable as she had hoped. From her table, she could see the whole of the city laid out beneath her, a patterned blanket of blinking lights beneath a darkening sky. It was amazing, she said later. We were looking out at the most spectacular view in the world, New York at night, when suddenly it disappeared. Now that, Dominic Sandbrook,
那闪闪发光的双子塔建成才不过几年，她乘电梯直达107层，来到“世界之窗”（Windows on the World），那是一家可以俯瞰整座城市的优雅餐厅。当然，那个夜晚正如她所期待的那样，格外美好且令人难忘。从餐桌旁望去，她可以看到脚下铺展开来的整座城市，在昏暗的天空下，那是一块闪烁着灯光的图案毯子。她后来回忆说，那真是太神奇了。我们正眺望着世界上最壮观的景色——夜晚的纽约，突然间，它消失了。多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook），
was written by a top historian of 1970s America in his magnum opus, Mad as Hell. And that author, I think, was commissioned to write 140,000 words, and he ended up writing 500,000 words. So hundreds of thousands of words had to be cut. Shaming. And that author, Dominic, was yourself. But these chapters on 70s America that had to be cut are all so good. So never let anything go to waste, Dominic. Listeners may remember the two episodes we did on The Fall of Saigon,
这段文字出自一位研究20世纪70年代美国的顶尖历史学家之手，收录于他的巨著《愤怒如火》（Mad as Hell）中。我想，那位作者当时被委托撰写14万字，结果他写了50万字。所以，几十万字不得不被删减。真是可惜。多米尼克，那位作者就是你自己。但这些关于70年代美国的删减章节都写得太好了。所以，多米尼克，千万别浪费任何东西。听众们可能还记得我们做过的关于“西贡陷落”的两期节目，
which we kind of cannibalized um chapters that you'd had to cut and today we are doing the same with a chapter on new york in the 70s yeah and we're doing that because um we're recording um this episode as part of the tour that we're doing of the united states um we did a show in Washington. And as part of that, we did an episode on Martin Luther King's great speech, I Have a Dream, which was the previous episode that went out. And now we've come to New York. We're in Central Park. And we are recording an episode that kind of begins with a blackout, the great blackout on the 13th of july 1977 yeah um so this is what um ivy stevens is looking from exactly the world trades the top of the world trade center she's
我们当时也是“回收利用”了你不得不删掉的章节。今天，我们也要对关于70年代纽约的章节做同样的处理。是的，我们这样做是因为我们正在进行美国巡回演出，我们正在录制这一期节目。我们在华盛顿做了一场演出，作为其中的一部分，我们录制了一期关于马丁·路德·金伟大演讲《我有一个梦想》的节目，那是上一期播出的内容。现在我们来到了纽约，身处中央公园。我们正在录制一期节目，故事始于一场停电，即1977年7月13日那场大停电。是的，这就是艾薇·史蒂文斯当时从世界贸易中心顶层所看到的，她
watching the lights across manhattan go out the city vanishes tom the city vanishes yes hello everybody we are in central park which is looking particularly fine today i have to say so if you hear a bit of noise in the background, that's what that is. Central Park, of course, today, Tom, a more salubrious place, I think it's fair to say, than it would have been if we'd been there in the summer of 1977, as we will see. And the blackout itself, which will be familiar to some American listeners, but probably not so familiar to those outside america and maybe even outside the city the story of the blackout itself we'll start with that and then we will widen it out to talk about
看着曼哈顿各处的灯光熄灭，城市消失了，汤姆，城市消失了。是的，大家好，我们现在在中央公园，我不得不说，今天的公园看起来格外美好。所以，如果你听到背景里有一点噪音，那就是原因所在。当然，汤姆，今天的中央公园比我们1977年夏天来的时候要宜人得多，正如我们稍后会看到的。那场停电本身，对一些美国听众来说可能很熟悉，但对美国以外，甚至对纽约市以外的人来说可能就不那么熟悉了。我们将从停电的故事开始，然后扩展开来谈谈
crime and the politics of new york in the 70s which is a fascinating story so the the blackout happens for various complicated reasons you want to go into them sure the technical reasons explain it in detail when people when people listen to the rest is history then they listen to it mainly for my knowledge of electricity generation techniques. The rest is industrial technology, is what we're all about. So New York and cities like it occasionally did suffer blackouts and brownouts, as they were called, in the 60s and 70s. And this one happens basically when lightning strikes an electricity substation on the Hudson River. So in that bit of purple prose that you read out there
70年代纽约的犯罪和政治，这是一个引人入胜的故事。停电是因为各种复杂的原因发生的，你想深入探讨一下吗？当然，技术原因，详细解释一下。当人们收听《历史余韵》时，他们主要是为了听我对电力生产技术的了解。我们关注的就是工业技术。所以，纽约和类似的城市在60和70年代偶尔会遭遇停电和减压供电。而这一次，基本上是因为闪电击中了哈德逊河上的一个变电站。所以，在你刚才读到的那段华丽的散文中，
about Ivy Stevens and her evening out, I mentioned how humid it is. I mean, anyone who's been to New York in midsummer knows it can be suffocatingly stifling and kind of, you know, thunderstorms in the air, which is exactly what happened this night in July 1977. So lightning strikes this substation, and there's a particular company
关于艾薇·史蒂文斯和她那个夜晚的出行，我提到了天气有多潮湿。我的意思是，任何在仲夏去过纽约的人都知道，那里可能会闷热得令人窒息，而且空气中弥漫着雷雨，这正是1977年7月那个夜晚发生的事情。所以闪电击中了这个变电站，而有一家特定的公司
that provided the electricity to New York, Con Ed, Consolidated Edison. And it had a systems operator on the day called William Durith. He basically is in charge of blacking out individual bits of the city to reduce demand on the other power lines so the power lines won't burn out. Yeah. And he's slow to do it. Because reading your account it actually reminded me of chernobyl so you know you always think things could always be worse yeah so he's in the control room and it's all going wrong and he's paralyzed because it
为纽约提供电力，那就是联合爱迪生公司（Con Ed）。那天有一位系统操作员叫威廉·杜里斯（William Durith）。他基本上负责切断城市各个区域的电力，以减少其他输电线上的负荷，防止输电线烧毁。是的。但他反应迟缓。因为读你的描述，这实际上让我想起了切尔诺贝利，所以你知道，你总会觉得情况可能会更糟。是的，所以他在控制室里，一切都在出错，他瘫痪了，因为
happens within a very short space of time he has very bad luck because he's fiddling with the lines and then lightning strikes again and knocks out another line. Now, what that means is that the remaining lines are carrying more load than they can bear, and they start to burn out. Unless you reduce the demand, then more lines will burn out. And that, of course, piles more pressure on the lines that are remaining. And you're into a situation where they'll all burn out. God, this is so impressive. This is absolutely very detailed knowledge, Tom.
这一切发生在极短的时间内。他运气非常不好，因为他正在摆弄线路，然后闪电再次击中，又击毁了另一条线路。现在，这意味着剩余的线路承载的负荷超过了它们的承受能力，它们开始烧毁。除非你减少需求，否则更多的线路会烧毁。而这当然会给剩余的线路带来更大的压力。你陷入了一种它们都会烧毁的境地。天哪，这太令人印象深刻了。汤姆，这是非常详细的知识。
The power pool dispatcher of New York State, a man called William Kennedy, he rings Dureth and he says to him, you've got to start shutting bits of the city down because otherwise the whole thing is going to blow. The minutes tick by, one line after another goes down. Eventually, there are only two lines into the city left carrying electricity. They're from Long Island and from New Jersey. And he is given the direct order,
纽约州的电力调度员，一个叫威廉·肯尼迪（William Kennedy）的人，他打电话给杜里斯，告诉他，你必须开始关闭城市的部分地区，否则整个系统都会崩溃。时间一分一秒地过去，一条接一条的线路断电。最终，只剩下两条通往城市的线路还在输电。它们分别来自长岛和新泽西。他接到了直接命令，
you have to basically shut this down now. And he's again slow to react. All lines out of the city, or into the city rather, end up burning out. So the city is reliant just on its own generators. And at 9.27, I think it is, the whole system collapses. The whole system grinds to a halt.
你基本上必须现在就关闭它。但他反应依然迟缓。所有离开城市，或者说进入城市的线路，最终都烧毁了。所以城市只能依靠自己的发电机。我想是在9点27分，整个系统崩溃了。整个系统陷入了停滞。
And all five boroughs of New York City. Yeah. In that instant, every light in the city flickered off. All five boroughs quite suddenly lost power. Subway trains wheezed to a halt. Elevators, air conditioners, televisions, refrigerators, everything stopped. Yeah. So very dramatic and like a movie.
纽约市的所有五个行政区。是的。在那一瞬间，城市里的每一盏灯都闪烁着熄灭了。所有五个行政区突然断电。地铁列车发出嘶嘶声停了下来。电梯、空调、电视、冰箱，一切都停止了。是的。所以非常戏剧性，就像电影一样。
Because the thing about New York is that almost everything that happens in New York is like a movie and new york is the great home of the disaster movie and this is the disaster movie to end all disaster movies tom so the only lights that are left are the aircraft beacons on top of the city bank building and the world trade center and the flame and the torch of the statue of liberty so everything else has gone completely pitch black. And the thing is, this is not unprecedented. So it had happened before in 1965, when 25 million people in New York, New Jersey, and New England had been left for hours without electricity. And in parts of New York, again in 1977, it's fine. So Ivy Stevens, I mean, she tells her story to the newspapers. She's just somebody
因为纽约的特点是，几乎发生在纽约的每一件事都像电影，而纽约是灾难片的大本营，这就是灾难片中的终极灾难片，汤姆。所以唯一剩下的灯光是城市银行大楼和世界贸易中心顶部的航空信标，以及自由女神像的火炬，所以其他一切都完全陷入了漆黑。问题是，这并非史无前例。1965年就发生过，当时纽约、新泽西和新英格兰的2500万人断电数小时。而在1977年的纽约，在某些地方，情况还好。所以艾薇·史蒂文斯，我的意思是，她向报纸讲述了她的故事。她只是一个
who's interviewed. And she'd gone out to the restaurant and actually it's lovely. It's all very civilized. You know, it's all very civilized. People bring champagne.
被采访的人。她去了餐厅，实际上那里很可爱。一切都非常文明。你知道，一切都非常文明。人们带来了香槟。
They have a lovely time at the Metropolitan Opera. The harpist strikes up dancing in the dark. Yeah. On the Upper East Side of the restaurants, they move all the tables
他们在纽约大都会歌剧院度过了一段美好的时光。竖琴手开始演奏《黑暗中的舞蹈》。是的。在上东区的餐厅里，他们把所有的桌子
out into the streets. It's too hot to be inside. No air conditioning. And they illuminate them with car headlights. people improvise and it's very fun and memorable and so this is the new york of uh annie hall of a woody allen comedy yeah um it's you know the civilized city exactly but new york in the 1970s is increasingly becoming a byword for urban dystopias exactly exactly and so what happens elsewhere when everything goes so the extraordinary thing is that within moments of the blackout happening the looting and the fighting starts so in alphabet city for example down towards the
搬到了街上。里面太热了，没法待。没有空调。他们用汽车前灯照亮它们。人们即兴发挥，非常有趣且令人难忘。所以这就是安妮·霍尔（Annie Hall）的纽约，伍迪·艾伦（Woody Allen）喜剧里的纽约。是的，你知道，这是文明的城市。但70年代的纽约正日益成为城市反乌托邦的代名词。没错，没错。那么当一切都发生时，其他地方发生了什么？非同寻常的是，停电发生后的瞬间，抢劫和打斗就开始了。例如，在曼哈顿岛南部的字母城（Alphabet City），
bottom of the island of manhattan people almost immediately start ransacking the shops smashing the windows grabbing stuff on the upper west side there are stories that store after store is pillaged 61 shops between 63rd street and 110th street alone on broadway just south of columbia university there are stories about people driving up to hi-fi shops with their trucks. They attach a hook to the grill, to the kind of gate, and then they drive away, rip the gate off, and then it's open season, everyone gets in and helps themselves. Well, you've got a very, I mean, a particularly poignant episode on Amsterdam Avenue.
人们几乎立即开始洗劫商店，砸碎窗户，抢夺东西。在上西区，有报道称商店一家接一家地被掠夺。仅在百老汇63街到110街之间就有61家商店被抢。在哥伦比亚大学南部的百老汇，有报道称人们开着卡车来到音响店。他们把钩子挂在格栅上，挂在那种大门上，然后开车离开，把门扯掉，然后就是“狩猎季节”了，每个人都进去拿自己想要的东西。嗯，你有一个非常，我的意思是，阿姆斯特丹大道上有一个特别令人心酸的片段。
A crowd break into a clothing store and just kind of make off with everything. And there's this middle-aged black woman outside pouring feebly at the looters with a broomstick. No, don't do it, please. They worked so hard. Don't, don't. Yeah. So they're actually quite tragic.
一群人闯进一家服装店，把所有东西都拿走了。外面有一个中年黑人妇女，正无力地拿着扫帚柄对着抢劫者挥舞。不，别这样，求求你们。他们工作得那么辛苦。别，别。是的。所以这些场景实际上相当悲惨。
Quite tragic scenes. People, you know, some of these are family businesses who are effectively on the verge of losing everything when people start looting. So Manhattan is bad. It's bad in Manhattan, but it's worse.
相当悲惨的场景。人们，你知道，其中一些是家族企业，当人们开始抢劫时，他们实际上处于失去一切的边缘。所以曼哈顿的情况很糟糕。曼哈顿很糟糕，但更糟糕的是
In the Bronx. So in the Bronx, 473 shops attacked. 961 looters are arrested. There's an Ace Pontiac car showroom and 200 people force their way into the showroom. Because of drive-off.
在布朗克斯区。在布朗克斯，473家商店遭到袭击。961名抢劫者被捕。有一家Ace庞蒂亚克汽车展厅，200人强行闯入展厅。因为可以开车离开。
And they just drive off with the cars. They drive off with 50 cars. One by one. In sort of single file, through the glass, out into the street. Brooklyn, even worse than the Bronx, 700 stores in Brooklyn were gutted, looted, burned, 1,000 people arrested.
他们就这样把车开走了。他们开走了50辆车。一辆接一辆。排成单行，穿过玻璃，开到街上。布鲁克林比布朗克斯更糟，700家商店被洗劫、抢劫、烧毁，1000人被捕。
And there's one neighborhood in particular that becomes synonymous with the blackout of 1977. It's called Bushwick. So Bushwick is off in northeastern Brooklyn. And by this point, it is predominantly black and Puerto Rican. And we'll talk a little bit later in the podcast about these neighborhoods where the demography had changed massively in the 1960s and 1970s. So Bushwick already in the 70s had a reputation for very high levels of people
有一个社区特别成为了1977年大停电的代名词。它叫布什维克（Bushwick）。布什维克位于布鲁克林东北部。到那时，它主要是黑人和波多黎各人居住区。我们稍后会在播客中谈论这些在60和70年代人口结构发生巨大变化的社区。所以布什维克在70年代就已经以极高水平的
on welfare, very high levels of violence and vandalism. It's basically not a place where tourists go Tom. So it's the kind of the reaches of Gotham city that Batman would be clearing up. The Batman will be clearing up or Batman might be slightly out of his depth. Really? Okay. Okay. That bad. So in Bushwick, I mean, we don't need to go through all the sort of stats and stuff, but all the descriptions of it are that in the center of the neighborhood, gangs are moving through within moments.
福利依赖、极高水平的暴力和破坏行为而闻名。汤姆，这基本上不是游客会去的地方。所以它是哥谭市（Gotham City）那些蝙蝠侠会去清理的角落。蝙蝠侠会去清理，或者蝙蝠侠可能会有点力不从心。真的吗？好吧。好吧。那么糟糕。所以在布什维克，我的意思是，我们不需要列举所有的统计数据之类的，但所有的描述都显示，在社区中心，帮派在瞬间就开始行动了。
It's as though they've been prepared, they've been ready, which of course they weren't, but people start moving through, looting shop after shop. They use trucks, they load furniture, hi-fis, televisions, all of these things. I mean, the thing is that I remember living through the London riots in 2011 when basically, I mean, it was a kind of a frenzy of looting and people just kind of got caught up on it. It all seemed, everybody was just piling in. And this is what happens, basically. It is what happens.
就好像他们已经准备好了，已经就绪了一样，当然他们并没有，但人们开始行动，洗劫一家又一家商店。他们使用卡车，装载家具、音响、电视，所有这些东西。我的意思是，我记得经历过2011年的伦敦骚乱，当时基本上，我的意思是，那是一种抢劫狂潮，人们只是被卷入其中。看起来每个人都在参与。这就是发生的事情，基本上。确实是这样。
So it's, I mean, here's one quote. People were grabbing shirts, pairs of pants, anything, running around and laughing. It was that they were suddenly free. So that's a radio reporter who's up in Harlem. This is a cop. A cop says, the looters swept through here like locusts. I've seen looting before, but this was total devastation.
所以，我的意思是，这里有一句引语。人们在抢衬衫、裤子，什么都抢，跑来跑去，大笑。就好像他们突然自由了。这是一个在哈莱姆区的电台记者的报道。这是一个警察。一个警察说，抢劫者像蝗虫一样横扫这里。我以前见过抢劫，但这简直是彻底的毁灭。
Smashing, burning as if people had gone crazy. They were like bluefish in a feeding frenzy. And it's not just, you know, the urban poor, is it? It's kind of affluent shoppers in midtown in Manhattan. Right. Kind of breaking in, grabbing pants. I mean, you've got the story of a woman who's spotted stuffing a bag of ice
砸碎、焚烧，就好像人们疯了一样。他们就像处于进食狂潮中的蓝鱼。而且不仅仅是，你知道，城市贫民，对吧？还有曼哈顿中城的富裕购物者。对。那种闯入，抢裤子的人。我的意思是，有一个故事说，一个女人被发现把一袋冰
into her very expensive designer handbag. Her Louis Vuitton handbag, Tom. She's stuffing a bag of ice into it. And the manager or somebody sees, another customer sees her and says, I'll call the manager. And she drops it and flees. But you think, what the hell?
塞进她非常昂贵的设计师手提包里。她的路易威登（Louis Vuitton）手提包，汤姆。她正把一袋冰塞进去。经理或某个人看到了，另一个顾客看到了她，说，我要叫经理。她扔下包逃跑了。但你会想，这到底是怎么回事？
If she's got enough for a Louis Vuitton handbag. I mean, this is very much a kind of Gotham City theme, isn't it? Oh, yeah. Of the crowds going wild. Yeah. It's that fear that underpins so many stories about New York, actually. The Batman story about batman as the
如果她有足够的钱买路易威登手提包。我的意思是，这非常有哥谭市的主题，不是吗？哦，是的。人群疯狂。是的。这种恐惧支撑着关于纽约的许多故事，实际上。关于蝙蝠侠作为
vigilante bringing order to this city that is permanently on the brink of right and that has kind of currency because the nypd new york police are overstretched and deeply mistrusted yes and kind of ravaged with corruption yeah and so they also are not in a good state. They're in a terrible state. And we'll get onto this in the second half, just why the NYPD are in such a terrible state in the 70s. But to go back to Bushwick, this place, which is the absolute epitome, the embodiment,
治安维持者给这个永久处于边缘的城市带来秩序的故事，对吧？这在某种程度上是有市场的，因为纽约警察局（NYPD）人手不足，且深受不信任，是的，而且饱受腐败困扰，是的，所以他们的情况也不好。他们处于一种可怕的状态。我们会在下半部分谈到这一点，谈谈为什么纽约警察局在70年代处于如此糟糕的状态。但回到布什维克，这个地方，它是绝对的缩影，是化身，
the symbol, the avatar of the lawlessness of that evening in the summer of 1977. The looting doesn't die down in Bushwick until just round about dawn. And when the sun rises, it reveals this neighbourhood that has been, it's basically been gutted. It's as though the people of the neighbourhood
是1977年那个夏夜无法无天的象征。布什维克的抢劫直到黎明时分才平息。当太阳升起时，它揭示了这个社区，它基本上已经被洗劫一空。就好像社区的人们
have sacked their own city. Well, can I read from your book, Dominic? Please do, Tom. Do you think the listeners would like to hear more of your prose? They probably wouldn't, but I'm sure you're going to do it anyway. Okay, I'm going to read it.
洗劫了他们自己的城市。好吧，我能读读你的书吗，多米尼克？请便，汤姆。你觉得听众想听更多你的散文吗？他们可能不想，但我肯定你无论如何都会读的。好吧，我要读了。
So along Broadway, this is in Bushwick, no fewer than 34 stores had been looted. 45 had also been set on fire. Most of Bushwick's buildings were made of timber and asphalt, a devastatingly flammable mixture. At one point, two entire blocks had been ablaze. When fire crews had reached the scene, they had been bombarded with rocks and sticks by jeering looters,
在百老汇沿线，这是在布什维克，不少于34家商店被抢劫。45家也被纵火焚烧。布什维克的大多数建筑都是用木材和沥青建造的，这是一种极易燃烧的混合物。有一次，整整两个街区都在燃烧。当消防队赶到现场时，他们遭到了嘲笑的抢劫者投掷的石块和棍棒的袭击，
and the police had even resorted to using a water cannon to protect the firemen. Now, in the cold light of morning 20 fires still burned and a cloud of black acrid smoke hung over the area it was a scene from a war zone a battlefield it was a scene from the end of the world yeah the potency of that scene from the point of view of those you know in the broader world is again that this is new york right exactly there's a a line by a guy i think he's from the miami chamber of commerce i was going to come up with it a bit later in the podcast but it's appropriate now he said um we knew exactly what to expect from new york and they didn't let us down uh which i think is a very sort of telling moment so to cut
警察甚至不得不使用高压水枪来保护消防员。现在，在清晨寒冷的阳光下，20处火灾仍在燃烧，一股黑色刺鼻的烟雾笼罩着该地区。这简直是战区的场景，战场。这简直是世界末日的场景。是的，从更广泛的世界的角度来看，那个场景的冲击力再次证明了这就是纽约，对吧？没错。有一个家伙说的一句话，我想他是来自迈阿密商会的，我本来打算在播客后面提到它，但现在很合适。他说，嗯，我们完全知道从纽约能期待什么，他们没有让我们失望。我认为这是一个非常说明问题的时刻。所以长话短说，
to the chase more than almost 2 000 stores were looted there were a thousand fires across the city roughly 4 000 people arrested and that is merely a fraction of the numbers that could have been arrested the police at one point tom are told to stop arresting people because they can't fit them into the cells and they're also told the time you're taking arresting people is time where you could have been on the streets. So they just beat looters up. So they just say, go and crack heads. Yeah.
超过2000家商店被抢劫，全市发生了1000起火灾，大约4000人被捕，而这仅仅是可能被捕人数的一小部分。汤姆，警察在某个时候被告知停止逮捕人，因为他们塞不进牢房了，而且他们还被告知，你花在逮捕人上的时间，本可以用来在街上巡逻。所以他们只是殴打抢劫者。所以他们只是说，去打破他们的头吧。是的。
Go and crack heads to try and stop it. So the costs are in the hundreds and hundreds of millions. And when does the power cut finish? So the power comes on towards the end of the following day. Right. So the 14th. So there's only one night. So it's one night and the best part of one day.
去打破他们的头，试图阻止它。所以损失高达数亿数亿。停电什么时候结束？电力在第二天快结束时恢复了。对。也就是14号。所以只有一晚。所以是一晚加上大半天。
Yeah. And intense heat. Anyone who's been to New York in the summer, imagine what it's like with no air conditioning, no fans, just stifling, stifling heat. And of course, for the press at the time, they see this as a symbol of all that's gone wrong with New York, which we'll get into.
是的。而且天气酷热。任何在夏天去过纽约的人，想象一下没有空调、没有风扇，只有闷热、令人窒息的热浪是什么感觉。当然，对于当时的媒体来说，他们认为这是纽约一切出错的象征，我们稍后会谈到这一点。
And there's one paper in particular, which we should talk about, which is the New York Post, whose headline is 24 hours of terror. It's a banner headline. why the new york post because the new york post just a few months earlier had been taken over it'd be founded by logan roy by logan roy exactly so the new york post a newspaper founded by hip-hop star alexander hamilton had been taken over by rupert murdoch so logan roy is the fictional incarnation of rupert
有一份报纸特别值得一提，那就是《纽约邮报》（New York Post），其头条是“24小时的恐怖”。这是一个横跨版面的大标题。为什么是《纽约邮报》？因为《纽约邮报》在几个月前被收购了，它是由洛根·罗伊（Logan Roy）创立的……由洛根·罗伊创立的，没错。所以《纽约邮报》，一份由嘻哈明星亚历山大·汉密尔顿（Alexander Hamilton）创立的报纸，被鲁珀特·默多克（Rupert Murdoch）收购了。所以洛根·罗伊是鲁珀特的虚构化身，
murdoch right in uh succession the tv drama british listeners will know rupert Murdoch. So Logan Roy is the fictional incarnation of Rupert Murdoch in Succession, the TV drama. Our British listeners will know Rupert Murdoch very well, as of course our American listeners will too. At the time,
默多克，对吧？在电视剧《继承之战》（Succession）中，英国听众会知道鲁珀特·默多克。所以洛根·罗伊是鲁珀特·默多克在电视剧《继承之战》中的虚构化身。我们的美国听众当然也会非常了解他。当时，
British newspaper readers would have known his name because he was the owner of The Sun. He's Australian, isn't he? He's Australian, the most aggressive tabloid, the most popular tabloid
英国报纸读者会知道他的名字，因为他是《太阳报》（The Sun）的老板。他是澳大利亚人，对吧？他是澳大利亚人，最激进的小报，最受欢迎的小报，
that someone should. That year, 1976, at the time when he took over The Post, had just overtaken the Mirror to become the biggest selling newspaper in Britain. Now, at the time, people said Murdoch will never hack it in America. He won't be a success. We won't like his formula. And they were, of course, completely wrong. So the Post, which was a kind of working class democratic newspaper, he said, we need to beef this up. What our readers want, they want a lot of stuff about crime they want scandals they don't have the the page three topless they don't have
有人应该……那一年，1976年，在他接手《邮报》时，它刚刚超过《镜报》（Mirror）成为英国销量最大的报纸。当时，人们说默多克永远无法在美国立足。他不会成功。我们不会喜欢他的模式。当然，他们完全错了。《邮报》原本是一份工人阶级的民主报纸，他说，我们需要加强它。我们的读者想要什么，他们想要很多关于犯罪的内容，他们想要丑闻。他们没有第三页的裸女，
topless girls in america which is a notorious thing that the sun has which yeah the sun had in britain everybody attacks murdoch and says he's a carpetbagger who cares about australians he brings in loads of british and australian journalists to run the new york post which is very controversial among American journalists. Because the London newspaper scene is actually much more competitive than the New York scene. Much more competitive. And frankly, Tom, much more exciting.
美国没有裸女，这是《太阳报》在英国臭名昭著的事情，是的，《太阳报》在英国有。每个人都攻击默多克，说他是投机分子，谁在乎澳大利亚人。他带来了大量的英国和澳大利亚记者来经营《纽约邮报》，这在美国记者中非常有争议。因为伦敦的报纸竞争实际上比纽约激烈得多。竞争激烈得多。坦率地说，汤姆，也精彩得多。
You know, because it's more cutthroat, you get better papers. And to Murdoch, the New York scene is very staid. And so he and the Post seize on the blackout, and they run story after story, front page after front page. And it sells kind of massively. They sold tens of thousands of extra copies
你知道，因为竞争更残酷，你会得到更好的报纸。对默多克来说，纽约的报纸界非常沉闷。所以他和《邮报》抓住了停电事件，他们一篇接一篇地报道，头版接头版。销量非常巨大。他们多卖了数万份，
based on their coverage of the blackout, of the looting. So Rupert Murdoch is, I mean, he's very conservative. He's very much on the right. Yes. So is he going in with a kind of law and order, string them up kind of approach? Absolutely, Absolutely. So the New York Post's attitude is the word that recurs again and again,
基于他们对停电和抢劫的报道。所以鲁珀特·默多克，我的意思是，他非常保守。他非常右倾。是的。所以他是否采取了一种“法律与秩序”、把他们吊起来的那种方式？绝对是，绝对是。所以《纽约邮报》的态度是，那个词反复出现，
which will make, I should imagine, many of our listeners shudder, is animals. They say again and again, the looters are animals, the looters are scum, the looters are the lowest of the low, all of this kind of thing. Now, that's a very common refrain on the right in America in the 70s. Are the left saying it's poverty? They are indeed. Deprivation. So to give you an example, somebody who's appeared on that podcast before,
我想这会让我们的许多听众不寒而栗，那就是“动物”。他们一遍又一遍地说，抢劫者是动物，抢劫者是人渣，抢劫者是最低贱的人，所有这些。现在，这是70年代美国右翼非常普遍的论调。左翼是否在说这是贫困造成的？他们确实在说。贫困。举个例子，之前出现在那个播客上的人，
Ronald Reagan, Tom. Well, he, yes. He blames the 60s. He says this is the legacy of the 60s. Hippies. All the conservative papers, the conservative columns are full of all this stuff. Human animals, the lowest of the low, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. The liberal papers, including the most famous New York paper of all,
罗纳德·里根（Ronald Reagan），汤姆。嗯，他，是的。他指责60年代。他说这是60年代的遗产。嬉皮士。所有的保守派报纸，保守派专栏都充斥着这些东西。人类动物，最低贱的人，等等等等。自由派报纸，包括纽约最著名的报纸，
the New York Times, are shocked by this. This is racist. You can't call people animals. And actually, the cause is unemployment. So Jimmy Carter, who was president in 1977, he does not condemn. He does not say this is all because of criminality he says it's because of unemployment it's a protest against unemployment that is the most common refrain among liberals now the new york times runs editorial after editorial on precisely these lines and gets an absolute
《纽约时报》（New York Times），对此感到震惊。这是种族主义。你不能称人为动物。实际上，原因是失业。所以吉米·卡特（Jimmy Carter），1977年的总统，他没有谴责。他没有说这完全是因为犯罪，他说这是因为失业，这是对失业的抗议。这是自由派中最常见的论调。现在，《纽约时报》发表了一篇又一篇社论，正是沿着这些思路，并收到了绝对
torrent of letters from readers who are appalled so i'll just read you um a couple of letters so this is from a fellow in Long Island. He says, your editorial was overloaded with a type of decrepit cliches, still believed only by sentimentalists, professional liberals, and your editorial board. The scars were inflicted by publicly funded demagogues who pander to our permanently established rabble. It's bad form to tell these parasites that looting, vandalism, arson, other violent crimes are no-nos. It's bad form to tell these parasites that looting, vandalism, arson, other violent crimes are no-nos. It's so much more profound, so much more chic to blather on about the debts which our society owes to its destroyers. It's a very strong, pungent stuff,
如潮水般的读者来信，他们感到震惊。所以我只读给你听……几封信。这是一位长岛读者的来信。他说，你们的社论充斥着那种只有感伤主义者、职业自由派和你们的编辑委员会才会相信的陈腐陈词滥调。这些伤疤是由那些迎合我们永久既定暴民的公共资助的煽动者造成的。告诉这些寄生虫说抢劫、破坏、纵火和其他暴力犯罪是不对的，这有失体面。告诉这些寄生虫说抢劫、破坏、纵火和其他暴力犯罪是不对的，这有失体面。喋喋不休地谈论我们社会欠其破坏者的债务，显得如此深刻，如此时髦。这真是非常强烈、辛辣的内容，
Tom. Pungent, yes. Pungent stuff. A man from Manhattan, Hendrik Root, I can't remember how to pronounce his name, Hendrik Root. Rootenbeek. Hendrik Rootenbeek. Maybe came over with the Dutch. With the Dutch, yeah. A Dutch holdout from New Amsterdam. He says, the warning should have gone out that every looter should be shot on the spot. The Puerto Ricans can go back to Puerto Rico. They belong there anyway. And if the blacks don't shape up, they can go back to the South. Now, these are shocking sentiments to us and to many of our listeners, I imagine.
汤姆。辛辣，是的。辛辣的内容。一位来自曼哈顿的亨德里克·鲁特（Hendrik Root），我不记得怎么发音他的名字，亨德里克·鲁特。鲁滕贝克（Rootenbeek）。亨德里克·鲁滕贝克。也许是随荷兰人来的。随荷兰人，是的。来自新阿姆斯特丹的荷兰遗民。他说，应该发出警告，每一个抢劫者都应该当场枪毙。波多黎各人可以回波多黎各去。他们本来就属于那里。如果黑人不改过自新，他们可以回南方去。现在，这些对我们和我们的许多听众来说是令人震惊的观点，我想。
But at the time, they are shocking sentiments to us and to many of our listeners, I imagine, but at the time they are absolutely widespread. There was this sort of, you know, America is in the grip of a kind of backlash, I guess, against what's seen of the excesses of the 60s. So Reagan's election is three years away and you can see the outline of the, well, tough on crime basically, not so much tough on the causes of crime. Absolutely. So Reagan, who's already been going around campaigning against welfare queens, as he calls them.
但当时，这些对我们和我们的许多听众来说是令人震惊的观点，我想，但在当时它们是绝对普遍的。有一种，你知道，美国正处于一种反弹的控制之中，我想，反对被视为60年代过激行为的东西。所以里根的当选还有三年，你可以看到那个轮廓，嗯，基本上是对犯罪强硬，而不是对犯罪的原因强硬。绝对是。所以里根，他已经到处竞选反对他所谓的“福利女王”。
We talked about this in our Reagan podcast. So Reagan, who... Well, I mean, shocking stuff from Patrick Buchanan. Oh, Patrick Buchanan, he writes. I mean, much further to the right than Reagan, right? Yeah. If hunger was in the back of it all, how come some of the welfare mamas
我们在我们的里根播客中谈过这个。所以里根，他……嗯，帕特里克·布坎南（Patrick Buchanan）的言论令人震惊。哦，帕特里克·布坎南，他写道。我的意思是，比里根更靠右，对吧？是的。如果饥饿是这一切的背后原因，为什么一些被拍到抢劫珠宝、服装和酒类商店的福利妈妈
filmed ripping off jewelry, clothing, and liquor stores lumbered about like overfed heifers who could use six months on a liquid protein diet yeah i mean that is pungent stuff that is yes um but he's i mean he's a quite a serious political figure isn't he well he had been he worked for nixon and then become a columnist at the new york post rival the daily news i think it was but um dominic one i mean one thing about this perhaps a point of intersection between the left and the right, between liberals and critics of the permissive society, is that a lot of the looting, you know, rather as that woman who I mentioned saying, you know, please don't do it, please don't do these stores are black owned. So in somewhere like Bushwick, those stores are owned by sort of black families, often a husband and wife operation,
像吃得过饱的小母牛一样走来走去，她们本可以进行六个月的液体蛋白质饮食。是的，我的意思是，那是辛辣的内容，是的……但他是，我的意思是，他是一个相当严肃的政治人物，不是吗？嗯，他曾经是，他为尼克松工作，然后成为《纽约邮报》竞争对手《每日新闻》（Daily News）的专栏作家，我想是这样。但是，多米尼克，关于这一点，也许是左翼和右翼、自由派和放纵社会批评者之间的一个交集，就是许多抢劫，你知道，就像我提到的那个女人说，你知道，请不要这样做，请不要这样做，这些商店是黑人拥有的。所以像布什维克这样的地方，那些商店是由黑人家庭拥有的，通常是夫妻经营，
kind of family businesses, and, you know, a lot of those people are ruined. They're not covered by insurance. If you don't have insurance, you're in real trouble. And actually one of these sort of great historic African-American papers in New York, the Amsterdam News, ran a front page editorial that was either reprinted or quote or extensively quoted by every
某种家族企业，而且，你知道，许多人被毁了。他们没有保险。如果你没有保险，你就真的有大麻烦了。实际上，纽约这些伟大的历史性非裔美国人报纸之一，《阿姆斯特丹新闻》（Amsterdam News），发表了一篇头版社论，被城市里的每一份
other newspaper in the city this is a newspaper by african-americans for african-americans and they had no time for the unemployment excuse we'll come on to the levels of unemployment in the second half they said it would be self-destructive and suicidal for us even to imply that we accept joblessness as a reason justifying looting. The looting was criminal, outrageous, and damnable. We cannot accept this behavior of our young people. We love them too much. We love our communities too much. We love those striving black businessmen and businesswomen too much. It has taken us too long to get where we are to accept such destructive behavior. What comes across from all this, whether it's on the left or the right,
其他报纸转载或广泛引用。这是一份由非裔美国人为非裔美国人创办的报纸，他们没有时间理会失业的借口。我们稍后会在下半部分谈到失业水平。他们说，即使暗示我们接受失业作为抢劫的理由，对我们来说也是自我毁灭和自杀性的。抢劫是犯罪、令人发指且该死的。我们不能接受我们年轻人的这种行为。我们太爱他们了。我们太爱我们的社区了。我们太爱那些努力奋斗的黑人商人和女商人了。我们走了太久才走到今天，不能接受这种破坏性的行为。从这一切中体现出来的，无论是左翼还是右翼，
black or white, whatever, is basically a kind of feeling of impotence and paralysis, a sense of a crisis that is so enormous that people don't really have solutions that they're kind of falling back on their gut political instincts their gut prejudices to explain this but the scale of the crisis is is really too great for any explanation and again just to reiterate because new york is what it is you know it is the the representative city of america which is the city that people imagine when they think of urban america therefore it is amplified globally in a way that it wouldn't be even in i don't know la or chicago i mean which i think that's right tom but i think something else on top of that which is that cities have riots i mean any city has the potential for a riot or for
黑人还是白人，无论如何，基本上是一种无能和瘫痪的感觉，一种巨大的危机感，以至于人们并没有真正的解决方案，他们只是退回到他们直觉的政治本能、他们的直觉偏见来解释这一点。但危机的规模确实太大，任何解释都无法涵盖。再次重申，因为纽约就是纽约，你知道，它是美国的代表城市，是人们想到城市美国时想象的城市，因此它在全球范围内被放大的方式，是洛杉矶或芝加哥所不会有的。我的意思是，我认为那是对的，汤姆，但我认为除此之外还有别的东西，那就是城市有骚乱。我的意思是，任何城市都有发生骚乱或
disorder these things happen they happen after you know how often do they happen after football matches or we talked about the 2011 riots in london exactly but the 1977 business feels different even to people at the time because it resonates because it expresses a kind of deeper truth about 70s New York, which is what we're going to get into. This sense that this wonderful urban project has turned into a living nightmare, that the city is a cesspit of crime, of corruption, which you see in so many Hollywood films in the 70s.
混乱的潜力，这些事情会发生。它们发生在，你知道，足球比赛后，或者我们谈论的2011年伦敦骚乱，正是如此。但1977年的事情即使对当时的人来说也感觉不同，因为它产生了共鸣，因为它表达了关于70年代纽约的一种更深层的真相，这正是我们要深入探讨的。这种感觉，这个美好的城市项目已经变成了一场活生生的噩梦，这个城市是一个犯罪和腐败的污水坑，你在70年代的许多好莱坞电影中都能看到这一点。
And that, I think, is a fascinating story. And that's what we'll get into. Should we do that after the break, Tom? Let's do that. Okay, very good. We'll take a break now, and we will return in the cesspit of crime and corruption of 70s New York. Fun times.
而且，我认为这是一个引人入胜的故事。这就是我们要深入探讨的内容。汤姆，我们休息一下再谈好吗？就这样吧。好的，非常好。我们现在休息一下，我们将回到70年代纽约那个犯罪和腐败的污水坑。有趣的时光。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman, and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment, and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad- ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐余韵》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先购买现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello welcome back to The Rest Is History and we are looking at New York in the 70s. Because I remember I was growing up in the 70s. You're not in New York, Tom, you're growing up in Wiltshire. I was growing up in Wiltshire, exactly, I was. Very much a place without drive-by shootings and graffiti and all that kind of thing. And my sense of New York was absolutely that it was the most terrifying place on earth. If I went there, I would probably get shot. So my association in New York was a terrifying place.
你好，欢迎回到《历史余韵》，我们正在审视70年代的纽约。因为我记得我在70年代长大。汤姆，你不在纽约，你在威尔特郡（Wiltshire）长大。我确实是在威尔特郡长大的，没错。那是一个没有驾车枪击、涂鸦和所有这些事情的地方。我对纽约的印象绝对是它是地球上最可怕的地方。如果我去那里，我可能会被枪杀。所以我对纽约的联想是一个可怕的地方。
It wasn't home of glamour. It wasn't the place that you can make it there, you can make it anywhere. It wasn't kind of Mad Men or anything like that. It was, I will get shot if I go there. I was kind of eight. I was going to tease you and say this is penetrating analysis. But actually, it's true. That's what people did think in the 70s.
它不是魅力的家园。它不是那种“如果你能在那里成功，你就能在任何地方成功”的地方。它不是《广告狂人》（Mad Men）之类的东西。它是，如果我去那里，我会被枪杀。我当时大约八岁。我本来想逗你一下，说这是深刻的分析。但实际上，这是真的。这就是人们在70年代的想法。
So it's kind of gut instinct. And had you been born 20 years earlier, you wouldn't have thought that. No. Because New York in the 50s and 60s was perceived abroad and in America as the epitome of everything that was most glamorous, most dazzling about American life. It's Don Draper in Mad Men. It's people drinking martinis.
所以这是一种直觉。如果你早出生20年，你就不会这么想了。不。因为50和60年代的纽约在国外和美国都被视为美国生活中最迷人、最耀眼的一切的缩影。那是《广告狂人》里的唐·德雷珀（Don Draper）。那是人们喝马提尼酒。
It's breakfast at Tiffany's. Audrey Hepburn. If you've ever seen, lots of our listeners would have seen North by Northwest. You know, Cary Grant.
那是《蒂凡尼的早餐》（Breakfast at Tiffany's）。奥黛丽·赫本（Audrey Hepburn）。如果你曾经看过，我们的许多听众可能看过《西北偏北》（North by Northwest）。你知道，加里·格兰特（Cary Grant）。
The cool of the city. The stylish lines of the buildings. Sharp suits. Sharp suits. Great dresses. Exactly. And that begins to change,
城市的酷。建筑的时髦线条。笔挺的西装。笔挺的西装。漂亮的裙子。没错。而这开始改变，
I would say, towards the end of the 60s. So at the beginning of 1966, New York gets a new mayor who's called John Vliet Lindsay. He is the person for whom the phrase, which some of our Americanists will be familiar with, limousine liberal, was applied to. And he is the absolute personification of kind of patrician, old money, the old elite, if you like. An elite that you can sort of trace back to the novels of henry james needed thwarton kind of gilded age new york so lindsey went to a boarding school americans don't often talk about this but a large part of their elite go to boarding schools so um lindsey went to a boarding school and he went to yale he's a very jfk-ish figure he's uh young handsome sporty civilized and in this symbolic moment on the day he takes office, there's a transport strike and he has to walk to work. And that sets the tone for the whole of his
我会说，在60年代末。所以1966年初，纽约迎来了一位新市长，名叫约翰·弗利特·林赛（John Vliet Lindsay）。他就是那个词——我们的美国研究者会很熟悉——“豪华轿车自由派”（limousine liberal）所指的人。他绝对是那种贵族、老钱、旧精英的化身。一种你可以追溯到亨利·詹姆斯（Henry James）小说中那种镀金时代纽约的精英。所以林赛上了一所寄宿学校，美国人通常不谈论这个，但他们很大一部分精英都上寄宿学校。所以，林赛上了一所寄宿学校，然后去了耶鲁大学。他是一个非常像JFK的人物，他年轻、英俊、运动、文明。在他上任的那天，在这个象征性的时刻，发生了一场交通罢工，他不得不步行上班。这为他的整个
administration. So there's constant strikes, money problems, rising crime. And actually, the issue is that something has gone badly wrong for New york as it has for so many american cities in the 60s and actually that anticipates what's going to happen to lots of cities elsewhere in the western world right so with your marxist hat on yeah um thanks what is happening is the expression of very very deep-seated economic revulsions and changes so what are they so the flight of manufacturing new york had been a great manufacturing city. The garment district in New York is the great symbol of that. People making all these clothes. Well,
政府定下了基调。所以有不断的罢工、金钱问题、犯罪率上升。实际上，问题在于纽约的情况变得非常糟糕，正如60年代许多美国城市一样，实际上这预示了西方世界许多其他城市将会发生什么。对吧？戴上你的马克思主义帽子，是的，谢谢。正在发生的是非常、非常深层的经济反感和变化的表现。那么它们是什么呢？制造业的流失，纽约曾经是一个伟大的制造业城市。纽约的服装区就是这一点的伟大象征。人们制作所有这些衣服。嗯，
that's been outsourced and as all has been, you know, it's happening abroad. Suburbanization, white middle-class people in particular are moving out to the suburbs, but also there's a big shift in America generally from what's called the rust belt. So those are the old industrial.
那已经被外包了，正如所有事情一样，你知道，它正在国外发生。郊区化，白人中产阶级尤其在搬往郊区，但美国总体上也发生了从所谓的“铁锈地带”（Rust Belt）的大规模转移。所以那些是旧的工业区。
Detroit is the kind of classic detroit pittsburgh cleveland cincinnati great cities great cities that have been the powerhouse of america but in the 70s the booming cities are dallas phoenix because they've suddenly got air conditioning because they've got air conditioning exactly i mean it seems like such a banal thing but air conditioning is one of the great transformative moments in American demographic history. Because now you can go and establish factories in the South and Southwest,
底特律是那种典型的底特律、匹兹堡、克利夫兰、辛辛那提，这些伟大的城市，曾经是美国的动力源，但在70年代，像达拉斯、凤凰城这样蓬勃发展的城市出现了，因为它们突然有了空调，因为它们有了空调，没错，这听起来似乎是一件很平庸的事情，但空调是美国人口史上最伟大的变革时刻之一。因为现在你可以去南方和西南地区建立工厂了，
where, by the way, they have quite restrictive anti-union laws. So for an employer, it actually makes sense. But also, isn't there also a sense that you can build factories and things from scratch there? Yes. Whereas in a city like New York, the infrastructure will often be quite antiquated. Exactly, yes.
顺便说一句，那里有相当严格的反工会法律。所以对于雇主来说，这实际上是有意义的。但此外，难道不也有一种感觉，就是你可以在那里从零开始建造工厂之类的东西吗？是的。而在纽约这样的城市，基础设施往往相当陈旧。没错，是的。
Crumbling, crumbling infrastructure. Crumbling infrastructure, yes. So, lots of particularly sort of more affluent, more educated white families moving out of New York and lots of new people moving in. I mean, this is nothing new. The whole thing about New York, the Statue of Liberty, huddled masses,
破败不堪，破败不堪的基础设施。破败不堪的基础设施，是的。所以，很多比较富裕、受教育程度较高的白人家庭搬离了纽约，同时也有很多新移民搬进来。我的意思是，这并不新鲜。关于纽约、自由女神像、拥挤的人群，整件事就是，
is that waves and waves of immigration come in and the city gives them jobs. But is it the case in the 70s that for the first time, there aren't the jobs available? There are two things. One, there is a class of people that had always been there in New York,
一波又一波的移民涌入，城市为他们提供工作。但在70年代，是否第一次出现了没有工作可做的情况？有两件事。第一，纽约一直有一类人，
who are now leaving, who are the more affluent people. Or someone like Brooklyn, or the Bronx even, white, working class, kind of inverted commas, and I know it's a heavy loaded word, sort of respectable working class families, they are moving out to the suburbs. And the people who are moving...
他们现在正在离开，也就是那些比较富裕的人。或者像布鲁克林，甚至布朗克斯，白人，工人阶级，所谓的，我知道这是一个沉重的词，那种体面的工人阶级家庭，他们正在搬到郊区。而那些搬进来的人……
To New Jersey. Yeah, exactly, to purpose-built estates and things. Whereas the people who are moving in, there are lots of migrants from the Caribbean, from Central America, from Puerto Rico, or African-Americans from the South. Now, in the past, as you said, loads of such people arrived in New York City,
去新泽西。是的，没错，去那些专门建造的住宅区之类的地方。而搬进来的人，有很多来自加勒比海、中美洲、波多黎各的移民，或者来自南方的非裔美国人。现在，过去正如你所说，大量这样的人来到纽约市，
but there were jobs. But actually now, there are not jobs. The economic obstacles to the newcomers are much greater than ever before. So in the month of the blackout july 1977 seven out of ten african-americans in new york are out of work and eight out of ten of the hispanic population so massive massive unemployment rates now as a result of that you get into a vicious spiral and tom i warn you there's going to be a tiny tiny bit of economics oh goodness so we've
但那时有工作。但实际上现在，没有工作了。新来者面临的经济障碍比以往任何时候都要大。所以在1977年7月大停电那个月，纽约十分之七的非裔美国人失业，十分之八的拉美裔人口失业，所以现在失业率非常非常高，结果就是你陷入了一个恶性循环，汤姆，我警告你，会有那么一点点经济学内容，哦天哪，所以我们
had industry yeah we've got economics well we've had the analysis of electricity generation yeah and now of tax bases because of course when you've got high unemployment you've got fewer people paying a lot of tax but you also have much bigger welfare roles yeah so what you have is that new york is making less money but it's liabilities. But having to spend more. And having to spend more. And that's not just New York. So Boston, Chicago, Detroit, Pittsburgh, some of those cities we mentioned. Well, Detroit, I mean, is basically collapsing. Well, it's not yet collapsing, but it's approaching the brink of it.
有了工业，是的，我们有了经济学，好吧，我们分析了电力生产，是的，现在又分析了税基，因为当然，当你失业率很高时，纳税的人就少了，但你的福利名单却长了很多，是的，所以纽约的情况是收入减少了，但负债却增加了。而且不得不花更多的钱。而且不得不花更多的钱。这不仅仅是纽约。波士顿、芝加哥、底特律、匹兹堡，我们提到的那些城市也是如此。嗯，底特律，我的意思是，基本上正在崩溃。嗯，还没有完全崩溃，但已经濒临边缘了。
So they're running up tens and tens of millions of debts. But nowhere is it worse than New York. So the merity of that guy that I mentioned, John Lindsay, ends up in a complete sort of disaster as he runs into financial problems. The city is losing hundreds of thousands of jobs every year. The deficit is getting bigger and bigger. So 1974, when Lindsay gives way to a new mayor, already the city has this reputation as a financial basket case i mean this is the new york times itself tom talking about its own city in 1974 new york city has become a metaphor for what looks like the last days of american civilization it's run by fools its citizens at the mercy of its criminals who often as not are protected by an unholy alliance of civil libertarians and crooked cops. The air is foul.
所以他们背负了数千万的债务。但没有哪里比纽约更糟糕了。所以我提到的那个家伙，约翰·林赛，在他遇到财务问题时，最终陷入了一场彻底的灾难。这座城市每年流失数十万个工作岗位。赤字越来越大。所以1974年，当林赛让位给新市长时，这座城市已经有了财务烂摊子的名声，我的意思是这是《纽约时报》自己在1974年谈论它自己的城市，纽约市已经成为美国文明末日的隐喻，它由傻瓜管理，市民任由罪犯摆布，而这些罪犯往往受到民权自由主义者和腐败警察的不圣洁联盟的保护。空气污浊。
The traffic is impossible. Services are diminishing, and the morale is such that ordering a cup of coffee in a diner can turn into a request for a fat lip. New York City is a mess, and it's getting worse all the time. So great stuff for the New York tourist board. Yeah, it's a great advert for the city. January 74, a new mayor comes in,
交通简直无法忍受。服务在减少，士气低落到在餐馆点一杯咖啡都可能招来一顿毒打。纽约市一团糟，而且情况越来越糟。这对纽约旅游局来说真是太棒了。是的，这对城市来说是个绝佳的广告。74年1月，一位新市长上任，
and he is basically a symbol of New York. He's a guy, he's very short. He's called abraham beam and uh he is the son of jewish immigrants from poland classic kind of people you'd get they're moving to the lower east side where so many eastern european jewish immigrants did he was born in 1906 like so many bright jewish poor boys he benefited from free education at the city College of New York. And then he became a democratic kind of machine politician. Was the financial controller.
他基本上是纽约的一个象征。他是个家伙，个子很矮。他叫亚伯拉罕·比姆，他是来自波兰的犹太移民的儿子，典型的你会看到的那种人，他们搬到了下东区，就像许多东欧犹太移民所做的那样，他出生于1906年，像许多聪明的犹太穷孩子一样，他受益于纽约城市学院的免费教育。然后他成为了一名民主党的机器政客。曾担任财务总监。
So he's meant to be the person with the figures. He becomes the mayor. When he comes in, the city is facing a complete financial meltdown. So he is basically having to borrow money at rates of 10%, interest rates of 10% just to pay the city's workers.
所以他本应是那个精通数字的人。他成为了市长。当他上任时，这座城市正面临彻底的金融崩溃。所以他基本上不得不以10%的利率借钱，10%的利息，仅仅是为了支付城市工人的工资。
Which presumably include cops, firemen, and people who collect the litter. All of those things. But people weren't lending the money. By the spring of 1975, he's basically staring into the abyss. He gets a loan from the state, New York State, but that even won't cover his own payroll.
这大概包括警察、消防员和清理垃圾的人。所有这些。但人们不愿借钱给他。到1975年春天，他基本上是在凝视深渊。他从州政府，纽约州，获得了一笔贷款，但这甚至无法支付他自己的工资单。
So he has to go to the federal government ronald reagan tom your mate who you impersonate so well ronald reagan said uh new york can just save itself he said new york must prove that it can handle its handle itself we shouldn't lend them any money but ronald reagan's rival gerald ford is president he obviously can't really allow the city to sink. But there is a famous headline, isn't there? There is. In the New York Post. Ford to city, drop dead, was the headline. Because they've asked him for a loan. They asked him for a bailout and he said no initially. Actually, that's a bit unfair on Ford. Ford does change his mind. He gives them a $2 billion loan guarantee bailout
所以他不得不去找联邦政府，罗纳德·里根，汤姆，你的那个你模仿得很好的伙伴，罗纳德·里根说，纽约可以自己拯救自己，他说纽约必须证明它能处理好自己的事情，我们不应该借给他们任何钱，但罗纳德·里根的竞争对手杰拉尔德·福特是总统，他显然不能真的允许这座城市沉没。但有一个著名的头条新闻，不是吗？确实有。在《纽约邮报》上。福特对城市说，去死吧，这是头条新闻。因为他们向他要求贷款。他们要求他救助，他最初拒绝了。其实，这对福特有点不公平。福特确实改变了主意。他给了他们20亿美元的贷款担保救助，
because if he didn't, the city would have collapsed. So the point where he does it, Abraham Beam, the mayor has just fired 63,000 people, including 10,000 teachers, 4,000 hospital staff, and thousands upon thousands of police and firemen. And this is an absolutely extraordinary story. So he fires all these people. He has to fire them. Thousands of people walk out. And the police, in particular, the police union, go absolutely ballistic.
因为如果他不这样做，这座城市就会崩溃。所以在他这么做的时候，市长亚伯拉罕·比姆刚刚解雇了63,000人，包括10,000名教师，4,000名医院工作人员，以及成千上万的警察和消防员。这是一个绝对非凡的故事。所以他解雇了所有人。他不得不解雇他们。成千上万的人走上街头。而警察，特别是警察工会，彻底暴走了。
So if you'd flown in, Tom, on holiday for a wheelchair, they would have given you at the airport, the members of the union would have greeted you with a leaflet that said, welcome to Fear City, and would have told you, don't use the subway, or don't leave your hotel after dark.
所以如果你当时飞过来，汤姆，去度假，他们会在机场给你，工会成员会用一张传单迎接你，上面写着，欢迎来到恐惧之城，并会告诉你，不要乘坐地铁，或者天黑后不要离开你的酒店。
You see, my father, I mean, basically he didn't like going to Salisbury. So there was no prospect of us going on holiday to New York. Well, to Fear City. Also, there are kind of millions of very fat rats scurrying everywhere on there. Yeah, that's right. So you're the winter discontent in Britain.
你看，我父亲，我的意思是，基本上他不喜欢去索尔兹伯里。所以我们根本没有去纽约度假的可能。好吧，去恐惧之城。此外，还有数百万只非常肥的老鼠在到处乱窜。是的，没错。所以你是英国的不满之冬。
Yeah, it's nothing. It's pitiful. This is like years of the winter of discontent. But with police handing out these leaflets saying you're going to be shot. I mean, at one point um police policemen who've been sacked block brooklyn bridge and then they put up barricades on brooklyn bridge and then throw beer bottles at people's cars it's absolutely i mean it really is like a batman film or. But Dominic, just to reiterate, I mean, the impact of this is in part because America and the world has a sense of New York.
是的，这算不了什么。这很可悲。这就像是多年的不满之冬。但警察分发这些传单说你会中枪。我的意思是，有一次，被解雇的警察封锁了布鲁克林大桥，然后他们在布鲁克林大桥上设置路障，然后向人们的汽车扔啤酒瓶，这绝对是，我的意思是，这真的就像一部蝙蝠侠电影或者。但多米尼克，重申一下，我的意思是，这产生的影响在一定程度上是因为美国和世界对纽约有一种感觉。
What happens in New York is always kind of extreme. It is, you know, the ultimate global city and basically has been throughout the 20th century. I love New York. I don't want to sound like we're reveling in this sort of dystopian nightmare because I actually love new york yeah of course but you can love new york and revel in in dystopia i mean that's kind of the whole point that you know you have awful things happening in new york and somehow it's material for a movie yeah of course it's material
发生在纽约的事情总是某种极端。它是，你知道，终极的全球城市，基本上整个20世纪都是如此。我爱纽约。我不想听起来好像我们在沉溺于这种反乌托邦的噩梦中，因为我实际上爱纽约，是的，当然，但你可以爱纽约并沉溺于反乌托邦，我的意思是，这正是重点，你知道，纽约发生了可怕的事情，而这不知何故成了电影的素材，是的，当然，它是素材，
for a movie so i mean we'll get into the films in just a second just on the last word on the nypd by the way the nypd i mean tony our producer who's listening to this is just in disbelief at some of these stories but the nypd had an appalling reputation in the 70s so there'd been a very famous story about this guy called frank serpico some people may have seen the film al Pacino serpico had been the first officer to speak out publicly about corruption, for which his colleagues had shot him in the face and then set him up and sort of framed him during a drugs raid. And he had testified and the story ended happily and he ended up being played by Al Pacino.
电影的素材，所以我的意思是，我们马上就会谈到电影，顺便说一句，关于纽约警察局的最后一句话，纽约警察局，我的意思是，正在听这个节目的我们的制片人托尼对其中一些故事感到难以置信，但纽约警察局在70年代的名声非常糟糕，所以有一个关于这个叫弗兰克·塞尔皮科的家伙的非常著名的故事，有些人可能看过那部电影，阿尔·帕西诺，塞尔皮科是第一个公开谈论腐败的警官，为此他的同事向他的脸开枪，然后在一次毒品突袭中陷害了他。他作证了，故事结局很圆满，他最终由阿尔·帕西诺扮演。
But basically, there's a big investigation called the Knapp Commission into corruption in New York City. And they find out that basically lots of officers have been taking bribes from drug dealers from pornography merchants they've been selling um heroin and cocaine they have been but they betray their own informants to the mob one thing they haven't been doing really is solving crime so you give the amazing stats between 1966 and 1973 the murder rate in new york went up 173% and rape by 112%. Yeah. Yeah.
但基本上，有一个名为纳普委员会的大型调查，调查纽约市的腐败问题。他们发现，基本上很多警官一直在从毒贩、色情商人那里收受贿赂，他们一直在兜售海洛因和可卡因，他们一直在这样做，但他们把自己的线人出卖给了黑帮，他们真正没做的一件事就是破案，所以你给出了惊人的统计数据，在1966年到1973年间，纽约的谋杀率上升了173%，强奸率上升了112%。是的。是的。
I mean, New York becomes... This is a problem, by the way, not just in America. It's a problem in lots of cities across the Western world. I don't want to sound like we're beating up on either New York or America. But New York does become the embodiment of this problem. Because then New York recovers. So the depth of the decline is what then sets up the of course the recovery in the 1990s and after and there are two elements by the
我的意思是，纽约变成了……顺便说一句，这是一个问题，不仅仅是在美国。这是西方世界许多城市面临的问题。我不想听起来好像我们在抨击纽约或美国。但纽约确实成为了这个问题的化身。因为后来纽约恢复了。所以衰落的深度正是后来促成1990年代及以后复苏的原因，顺便说一句，有两个因素，
way let's go back to the blackout for a second in that summer july 1977 that captured public attention so the first is the problem of gangs of young people's gangs so just a few days before the blackout time magazine had run a cover story on what it called the youth crime plague. Most extraordinary claim. People have always accused kids of getting away with murder. Now that's all too literally true. Across the US, a pattern of crime has emerged
让我们回到大停电，在那年夏天，1977年7月，这引起了公众的关注，所以第一个是年轻人帮派的问题，所以就在大停电前几天，《时代》杂志刊登了一篇封面故事，关于它所谓的青年犯罪瘟疫。最非凡的说法。人们总是指责孩子们逃脱了谋杀罪。现在这完全是字面意义上的真实。在美国各地，一种犯罪模式已经出现，
that's both perplexing and appalling. Many youngsters appear to be robbing and raping, maiming and murdering as casually as they go to a movie or go to a baseball game i mean this is kind of standard moral panic isn't it i mean oh there is a moral panic absolutely we had it with mods and rockers in britain yeah but this is on a different league so tom do you remember i i went to a summer camp when i was a boy and um in america no in england and they're sort of the teenage volunteers who meant to be looking after us
既令人困惑又令人震惊。许多年轻人似乎在抢劫、强奸、伤害和谋杀，就像他们去看电影或去看棒球比赛一样随意，我的意思是这是一种标准的道德恐慌，不是吗？我的意思是，哦，这绝对是一种道德恐慌，我们在英国也有过摩登族和摇滚族的恐慌，是的，但这完全是另一个级别，所以汤姆，你还记得吗，我小时候参加过一个夏令营，嗯，在美国，不，在英国，那些本该照顾我们的十几岁的志愿者，
who are about nine, decided that the appropriate film to put on was a film directed by Walter Hill released in 1979 called The Warriors. Have you ever seen that? I remember The Warriors.
大约九岁，决定放映的电影是沃尔特·希尔在1979年导演的一部电影，叫《战士帮》。你看过吗？我记得《战士帮》。
Yeah, it's based on Xenophon. About the March of the 10,000. The March of the 10,000. So a Greek army of mercenaries who get stranded in the middle of Iraq and have to get back to the... Back to Greece.
是的，它是基于色诺芬的作品。关于一万人的远征。一万人的远征。所以一支希腊雇佣军被困在伊拉克中部，必须回到……回到希腊。
Back to the sea. And they have to sort of march their way fighting. Yeah. So this is what happens in the film. iraq yeah and have to get back to the back to greece back to the back to the sea and they have to sort of march their way fighting and yeah so this is what happens in the film there's even a character called cyrus yes so either the gang is called cyrus yes and he says let's all the gangs join together and take over the city and one gang gets stranded or something have to fight their way out of new york i think i mean it was absolutely terrifying when i saw it was i was eight and i think it's a 18 certificate. But anyway, so there's a massive moral panic about gangs and about youth crime. But I mean, obviously, the scale of that is not accurate. I mean, they're hyping that up.
回到海边。他们必须一路战斗回去。是的。所以这就是电影里发生的事情。伊拉克，是的，必须回到希腊，回到海边，他们必须一路战斗回去，是的，所以这就是电影里发生的事情，甚至有一个角色叫赛勒斯，是的，所以帮派叫赛勒斯，是的，他说让所有帮派联合起来接管城市，然后一个帮派被困住或者什么，必须一路杀出纽约，我想，我的意思是，当我八岁时看它时，它绝对令人恐惧，我想它是18禁的。但无论如何，所以关于帮派和青少年犯罪存在巨大的道德恐慌。但我的意思是，显然，那个规模是不准确的。我的意思是，他们在夸大其词。
These are the armies of the night. They are 100,000 strong. They outnumber the cops five to one. They could run New York City. That's the tagline of the posters. No, but there were 20,000 gang members in New York City. That's the tagline of the posters. No, but there were 20,000 gang members in New York City. So a lot. Yeah. The other thing that's a big panic is, now some of our listeners will have been waiting for this because they'll remember it.
这是黑夜的军队。他们有10万人之众。他们的人数是警察的五倍。他们可以统治纽约市。这是海报上的标语。不，但纽约市有2万名帮派成员。这是海报上的标语。不，但纽约市有2万名帮派成员。所以很多。是的。另一件引起巨大恐慌的事情是，现在我们的一些听众可能一直在等待这个，因为他们会记得它。
Son of Sam, the serial killer. So the disco killer, as he's called. He killed six people in Queens and in the Bronx between the summer of 1976 and the summer of 1977. And he is basically the kind of, the love child of Jack the Ripper and the Joker of 1977. And he is basically the kind of, the love child of Jack the Ripper and the Joker. Right. Golly.
山姆之子，连环杀手。所以迪斯科杀手，正如他被称为的那样。他在1976年夏天到1977年夏天之间在皇后区和布朗克斯杀害了六个人。他基本上是开膛手杰克和1977年的小丑的爱情结晶。他基本上是开膛手杰克和小丑的爱情结晶。对。天哪。
Just as Jack the Ripper sent a letter to the police. Yeah. So Son of Sam sends a letter to the Daily News columnist, Jimmy Breslin. He does. Hello from the gutters of NYC, which are filled with dog manure, vomit, stale wine, urine and blood.
就像开膛手杰克给警察写信一样。是的。所以山姆之子给《每日新闻》的专栏作家吉米·布雷斯林写了一封信。他确实写了。来自纽约市阴沟的问候，那里充满了狗粪、呕吐物、陈酒、尿液和鲜血。
So more excellent copy for the New York tourist board. Hello from the seters of NYC, which are filled with dog manure, vomit, stale wine, urine, and blood. So more excellent copy for the New York tourist board. Hello from the sewers of NYC, which swallow up these delicacies when they are washed away by the sweeper trucks. Hello from the cracks in the sidewalks of NYC and from the ants that dwell in these cracks and feed on the dried blood of the dead that has settled into these cracks. So great stuff. I mean, you said about york being like a film set i mean the son of sam stuff feels like a batman movie a really dark batman movie yeah i mean he kills six people and presumably is an influence then on oh and subsequent kind of
所以这对纽约旅游局来说是更多优秀的文案。来自纽约市阴沟的问候，那里充满了狗粪、呕吐物、陈酒、尿液和鲜血。所以这对纽约旅游局来说是更多优秀的文案。来自纽约市下水道的问候，当它们被清扫车冲走时，这些美味佳肴就被吞噬了。来自纽约市人行道裂缝的问候，以及居住在这些裂缝中并以沉淀在这些裂缝中的死者干血为食的蚂蚁的问候。所以很棒的东西。我的意思是，你说纽约就像一个电影布景，我的意思是山姆之子的东西感觉像一部蝙蝠侠电影，一部非常黑暗的蝙蝠侠电影，是的，我的意思是，他杀了六个人，大概是对……产生了影响，哦，以及随后的那种
dystopian undoubtedly because batman in the 60s is adam west it's all you know it's a joke it's kind of yeah very funny but then subsequently batman has become a much darker figure right and presumably that is kind of drawing on the legacy of this age oh undoubtedly so the um yurkin phoenix portrayal of the joker i mean it sounds very son of sam yeah the hacking phoenix um or the heath ledger joker actually yes in the christopher nolan films exactly because son of sam who's actually a person he's a loner classic serial killer guy called david berkowitz he's constantly sending letters to jimmy brislin to this columnist i am the monster i love to hunt i'll be back i will haunt you all this sort of thing so you might well say well why just before we get into the
反乌托邦，毫无疑问，因为60年代的蝙蝠侠是亚当·韦斯特，全是，你知道，一个笑话，有点，是的，非常有趣，但随后蝙蝠侠变成了一个更黑暗的人物，对吧，大概这在某种程度上借鉴了这个时代的遗产，哦，毫无疑问，所以，嗯，杰昆·菲尼克斯对小丑的刻画，我的意思是，听起来非常像山姆之子，是的，杰昆·菲尼克斯，或者希斯·莱杰的小丑，其实是的，在克里斯托弗·诺兰的电影里，没错，因为山姆之子，他实际上是一个人，他是一个孤独者，典型的连环杀手，一个叫大卫·伯科维茨的家伙，他不断地给吉米·布雷斯林写信，给这个专栏作家，我是怪物，我喜欢狩猎，我会回来的，我会缠着你们所有人，诸如此类，所以你很可能会说，好吧，为什么，就在我们进入
more about the films why is crime out of control? There's one very banal reason. Well, if they've sacked all the police. Well, they've sacked all the police. That's not helpful, is it? But crucially, they've opened the floodgate. They've opened the gates of New York's psychiatric hospitals. Again, very Batman.
更多关于电影的内容之前，为什么犯罪失控了？有一个非常平庸的原因。好吧，如果他们解雇了所有的警察。好吧，他们解雇了所有的警察。这没用，不是吗？但至关重要的是，他们打开了闸门。他们打开了纽约精神病院的大门。同样，非常蝙蝠侠。
Yeah, Arkham Asylum. So in a series of decisions, partly there's been pressure for years for community care, community mental health, don't institutionalize people um the supreme court had ruled in 1975 that people who are mentally ill can't be detained unless they are definitely a threat to other people so across america hundreds of thousands of people who previously have been in hospitals i mean it also helps if you want to make cuts by the way the budgetary reasons
是的，阿卡姆疯人院。所以在一系列决定中，部分原因是多年来一直有压力要求社区护理、社区心理健康，不要将人们机构化，嗯，最高法院在1975年裁定，精神病患者不能被拘留，除非他们绝对对他人的安全构成威胁，所以在美国各地，成千上万以前一直在医院里的人，我的意思是，如果你想削减开支，顺便说一句，出于预算原因，这也有帮助，
so they have basically been decanted onto the streets many of those people are now homeless roaming the streets in manhattan and elsewhere those scenes that many of us who've been to new york particularly went to new york in the bad old days will recall of people pushing their possessions in kind of shopping trolleys or dragging them behind them. I mean, these people are often former psychiatric patients who have basically been abandoned by the system, thrown out onto the streets. So there are some estimates that in the early 1980s, about between a third and a half of the city's homeless population
所以他们基本上被倾倒到了街上，许多人现在无家可归，在曼哈顿和其他地方流浪，我们许多去过纽约，特别是去过纽约那些糟糕的旧日子的人会记得那些人推着他们的财物，用那种购物手推车，或者拖在他们身后。我的意思是，这些人通常是以前的精神病患者，基本上被系统抛弃，扔到了街上。所以有一些估计认为，在1980年代初，该市约三分之一到一半的无家可归人口
were previously people who'd been having treatment, who were basically thrown out onto the streets. So there's this sort of sense, and you take that that the lack of jobs this the degradation of the urban environment because of the financial problems there is this the lack of human resources the lack of police of exactly sanitation workers of firefighters then there's drug addiction and then there's also the fact the city's environment itself has been radically reshaped by planners are planners like the most famous guy, a guy called Robert Moses. Robert Caro wrote this fantastic book called The Power Broker about how you reshape New York with expressways, cutting through what had once been settled, kind of contented working class neighborhoods,
以前是接受过治疗的人，基本上被扔到了街上。所以有一种感觉，你考虑到缺乏工作，由于财务问题导致的城市环境退化，缺乏人力资源，缺乏警察，缺乏环卫工人，缺乏消防员，然后还有毒品成瘾，然后还有城市环境本身被规划者彻底重塑的事实，规划者就像最著名的人，一个叫罗伯特·摩西的家伙。罗伯特·卡罗写了这本精彩的书《权力掮客》，关于你如何用高速公路重塑纽约，切断曾经定居的、那种满足的工人阶级社区，
you know, buildings, entire streets, entire blocks ripped out to make way for these kind of under passes and over passes and things so there's a sense that the city has lost its self-belief it's it's lost its sheen lost its soul yeah lost its soul all the glitter and glamour i mean there's a very famous moment that epitomizes this in the bronx so the south bronx have been eviscerated by the cross bronx Expressway this disastrous project that ripped through neighbourhoods and is that the
你知道，建筑物、整条街道、整个街区被拆除，为这些地下通道和立交桥之类的地方让路，所以有一种感觉，这座城市失去了自信，失去了光泽，失去了灵魂，是的，失去了灵魂，所有的浮华和魅力，我的意思是，在布朗克斯有一个非常著名的时刻体现了这一点，所以南布朗克斯被横贯布朗克斯高速公路掏空了，这个灾难性的项目撕裂了社区，那是
expressway that in Bonfire of Vanities oh yeah it might be actually the Tom Wolfe novel where the yuppie accidentally
在《虚荣的篝火》里的那条高速公路吗？哦，是的，其实可能是汤姆·沃尔夫的小说，那个雅皮士不小心
goes off the wrong I think you might be right actually Tom I mean you're right because Bonfire of the Vanities the Tom Wolfe book is written I suppose you would say
走错了路，我想你可能是对的，汤姆，我的意思是你是对的，因为《虚荣的篝火》，汤姆·沃尔夫的书是写于，我想你会说
at the very end of this period in the 1980s the masters of the universeities, the whole Tom Wolfe book, is written, I suppose you would say, at the very end of this period, in the mid-1980s. Yes, so it's the masters of the universe have returned to Wall Street. Right. But there's still that kind of dread of what happened. Well, I suppose it kind of haves and have-nots by that point. Exactly.
在这个时期的最末端，在1980年代，宇宙的主宰们，整本汤姆·沃尔夫的书，是写于，我想你会说，在这个时期的最末端，在1980年代中期。是的，所以是宇宙的主宰们回到了华尔街。对。但仍然有一种对所发生事情的恐惧。好吧，我想在那时它有点像富人和穷人。没错。
But the Bronx is also home to Yankee Stadium. And in the World Series in October 1977, so we're talking just a couple of months after the blackout, the Yankees are playing the Los Angeles Dodgers. And while the game is on tv there's a building behind the stadium that has caught fire and the the announcer this guy howard cosell who was one of the most famous american sports commentators says there it is ladies and gentlemen the bronx is burning and those words kind of the bronx is burning became this kind of catchphrase this metaphor for the immolation of the kind of the bronx is burning became this kind of catchphrase this metaphor for the immolation of the kind of east coast urban dream and that of course is the background tom for all those films
但布朗克斯也是洋基体育场的所在地。在1977年10月的世界大赛中，所以我们谈论的是大停电后仅仅几个月，洋基队正在对阵洛杉矶道奇队。当比赛在电视上播出时，体育场后面的一栋建筑着火了，播音员，这个叫霍华德·科塞尔的家伙，他是美国最著名的体育评论员之一，说，就在那里，女士们先生们，布朗克斯正在燃烧，而那些话，某种程度上，布朗克斯正在燃烧，成为了这种口头禅，这种对东海岸城市梦想毁灭的隐喻，布朗克斯正在燃烧，成为了这种口头禅，这种对东海岸城市梦想毁灭的隐喻，而这当然是汤姆所有这些电影的背景，
so we said we'd talk about films we could spend the rest of the podcast just listing them saturday night fever saturday night fever they embrace disco because they want to escape the reality of a decaying decrepit brook And it's a pretty depressing film. Very depressing film. Not as depressing as Dog Day Afternoon or Death Wish. Death Wish is a very dark film. Or the most famous one, which lots of our listeners will be familiar with, is Taxi Driver. So amazingly, given what we're saying about Son of Sam,
所以我们说我们要谈论电影，我们可以花剩下的时间列举它们，《周末夜狂热》，《周末夜狂热》，他们拥抱迪斯科，因为他们想逃避一个腐烂、破败的布鲁克林的现实。而且这是一部相当令人沮丧的电影。非常令人沮丧的电影。不如《炎热的下午》或《猛龙怪客》令人沮丧。《猛龙怪客》是一部非常黑暗的电影。或者最著名的一部，我们的许多听众会很熟悉，是《出租车司机》。所以令人惊讶的是，考虑到我们所说的关于山姆之子的内容，
Taxi Driver comes first. So Taxi Driver. So that's the still fecund Robert De Niro. Yes. I didn't think you'd be going there, Tom, but you did. He's about 120 now, isn't he? He is. But he's still fathering those children.
《出租车司机》排在第一位。所以《出租车司机》。所以那是仍然多产的罗伯特·德尼罗。是的。我没想到你会提到那个，汤姆，但你提到了。他现在大约120岁了，不是吗？他是。但他还在生那些孩子。
He is. So he plays in that film, 75. He plays Travis Bickle. He's a Vietnam veteran traumatized by the war, drives a yellow cab in New York City. He is deeply disturbed. He is disturbed by the seediness, the sleaze, the crime. I mean, he famously says the city is an open sewer full of filth and scum. Someday a real rain will come and wash all this scum off the
他是。所以他在那部电影里，75年。他扮演特拉维斯·比克尔。他是一名被战争创伤的越战老兵，在纽约市开黄色出租车。他深受困扰。他被肮脏、卑劣、犯罪所困扰。我的意思是，他著名地说这座城市是一个充满污秽和渣滓的露天污水沟。总有一天，一场真正的雨会来，把这些渣滓从
streets. Yeah. And he becomes a hero. I mean, that's the irony of the film. This very damaged, disturbed man becomes a crime-fighting hero at the end of the film. He's lauded by the city for having, in a very bloody fashion, cleaned the scum off the streets, as it were. And he's a sort of a sick hero for a sick city, I think that's the... A sick hero for a sick city.
街道上冲走。是的。他成了一个英雄。我的意思是，这就是电影的讽刺之处。这个非常受损、受困扰的人在电影结尾成了一个打击犯罪的英雄。他因以一种非常血腥的方式清除了街上的渣滓而受到城市的赞扬。他是一个病态城市的病态英雄，我想这就是……病态城市的病态英雄。
Yeah. You should be writing movie strap lines. I'm wasted on history. So, of course, the other thing that all those films are are the background for the blackout so when the blackout happens that quote it was i i anticipated in the first half from the miami chamber of commerce of course miami is one of those cities that has prospered while new york has decayed it's just about what you would expect from new york most of us expected the worst they didn't let us down joe biden tom yeah joe biden said new york is seen as the seed of corruption and duplicity you know all this i mean people don't feel sorry for new york that's the astonishing thing there's
是的。你应该去写电影宣传语。我浪费在历史上了。所以，当然，所有这些电影的另一件事是它们是大停电的背景，所以当大停电发生时，那句引语，我在前半部分预料到了，来自迈阿密商会，当然，迈阿密是那些在纽约衰落时繁荣起来的城市之一，这正是你对纽约的期望，我们大多数人预料到了最坏的情况，他们没有让我们失望，乔·拜登，汤姆，是的，乔·拜登说纽约被视为腐败和虚伪的温床，你知道这一切，我的意思是人们并不为纽约感到难过，这是令人震惊的事情，有
a line in annie hall where uh where woody allen says everybody thinks we're communist left-wing draft dodging pornographers yeah and he said nice says that and i live here and um and i think that's, you know, that terrible, terrible image. But New Yorkers take a pride in it,
《安妮·霍尔》里有一句台词，伍迪·艾伦说每个人都认为我们是共产主义、左翼、逃避兵役的色情狂，是的，他说好，他说那，我住在这里，嗯，我认为那是，你知道，那种可怕、可怕的形象。但纽约人以此为荣，
don't they? I mean, there's a kind of sense that, you know, we're the meanest of the mean, we're the baddest of the bad to a degree. I think after July 1977.
不是吗？我的意思是，有一种感觉，你知道，我们是最卑鄙的，我们是坏人中的坏人，在某种程度上。我想在1977年7月之后。
Well, because the city then does stage a miraculous recovery. It's not instant. No, but by the late 80s, you know, Manhattan again is a byword for wealth and glamour and sophistication. It's not instant. No, but by the late 80s, you know, Manhattan again is a byword for wealth
好吧，因为这座城市随后确实上演了奇迹般的复苏。这不是瞬间的。不，但到了80年代末，你知道，曼哈顿再次成为财富、魅力和精致的代名词。这不是瞬间的。不，但到了80年代末，你知道，曼哈顿再次成为财富
and glamour and sophistication. It does. And actually, that's another story in and of itself, which we don't have time to get into. But we could maybe do it sometime.
和魅力与精致的代名词。确实。而且实际上，那是另一个故事，我们没有时间深入探讨。但我们也许可以在某个时候做。
Which we can maybe do it sometime. Yeah, how the city turns it around, all the controversies about policing in the 1990s. What was the film in which New York becomes a prison
我们也许可以在某个时候做。是的，这座城市是如何扭转局面的，关于1990年代警务的所有争议。纽约变成监狱的那部电影是什么
and the president kind of crashes into it or something? Escape from New York. Escape from New York. With Kurt Russell. Yeah. Plays a character called Snake Plissken. Let's watch that again.
总统撞进去了还是什么的？《逃出纽约》。《逃出纽约》。库尔特·拉塞尔主演。是的。扮演一个叫大蛇普利斯金的角色。让我们再看一遍。
So two notes on which to end. First of all, two consequences that both happened here in New York, Tom, where we are today, but both had wider national consequences. So the first comes just a few months after the blackout. So there's going to be a mayoral election. And Abraham Beam, this guy we described, Lower East Side, Jewish immigrants, the sort of soul of the old-fashioned
所以以两个音符结束。首先，两个后果都发生在这里，纽约，汤姆，我们今天所在的地方，但两者都有更广泛的国家后果。所以第一个发生在大停电后仅仅几个月。所以将会有市长选举。亚伯拉罕·比姆，我们描述的这个家伙，下东区，犹太移民，那种老式
social democratic New York, I suppose, he is dumped by the Democrats and replaced with a guy who's the future. He's a guy called Ed Koch. And Ed Koch had had been i thought it was ed koch ed koch but you can call him that if you like i think it's i believe it's ed koch ed koch okay i mean wisely a wise choice from ed koch if you want a political career i think anyway he um he had been a loyal liberal democrat and now he says i'm a liberal but with sanity meaning tough
社会民主纽约的灵魂，我想，他被民主党抛弃了，取而代之的是一个代表未来的人。他叫埃德·科赫。埃德·科赫曾，我以为是埃德·科赫，埃德·科赫，但如果你喜欢你可以那样叫他，我想它是，我相信是埃德·科赫，埃德·科赫，好吧，我的意思是，如果你想要政治生涯，埃德·科赫是一个明智的选择，我想，无论如何，他，嗯，他曾是一位忠诚的自由派民主党人，现在他说我是自由派，但有理智，意味着对
on crime tough on the causes of crime exactly so he runs in 1977 as a populist and he says you know he's kind of abrasive and he's tough talk he says i'll i'll crack down on the unions i'll crack down on crime he talks about he's very keen on the death penalty all this sort of stuff and when he comes in he takes what he sees as the tough decisions that beam wouldn't take he slashes the city's budget he raises all the subway fares he confronts the unions and tom he thinks that the way to one of the ways to rebuild the city is to allow private developers more of a free hand private i now hunch where you're going with this so i mentioned developers this is the other thing one man's crisis is another man's opportunity yeah so as new york declines decays
犯罪强硬，对犯罪的原因强硬，没错，所以他在1977年作为民粹主义者参选，他说，你知道，他有点尖刻，他说话强硬，他说我会打击工会，我会打击犯罪，他谈到他非常热衷于死刑，所有这些东西，当他上任时，他做出了他认为比姆不会做的艰难决定，他削减了城市预算，他提高了所有地铁票价，他对抗工会，汤姆，他认为重建城市的方法之一是让私人开发商有更多的自由，私人，我现在预感你要去哪里了，所以我提到了开发商，这是另一件事，一个人的危机是另一个人的机会，是的，随着纽约衰落、腐烂，
you've got burned out hotels and all the rest of it some people see in this a chance to make some money now there's one place in particular where they say this is a corner of midtown manhattan it's right next to grand central station grand central of course decaying at the time but a symbol of an earlier golden age kind of new york so on east 42nd street between lexington and park avenue not a million miles from where we are now there was a hotel called the commodore and it had been known by the pen central railroad which had gone bust in 1976. And the hotel was derelict. At the time of the blackout, the hotel is completely derelict.
你有烧毁的酒店和所有其他东西，有些人从中看到了赚钱的机会，现在有一个地方特别，他们说这是曼哈顿中城的一个角落，就在中央车站旁边，中央车站当然在当时正在衰落，但它是早期黄金时代纽约的象征，所以在大中央车站东42街，在列克星敦大道和公园大道之间，离我们现在所在的地方不远，有一家叫准将的酒店，它曾被1976年破产的宾夕法尼亚中央铁路公司拥有。酒店被废弃了。在大停电时，酒店完全被废弃了。
There are rats in the basement. A lot of the rooms have been taken over by prostitutes. Super villains are plotting death rays in the basement. Right. All that kind of thing. And there's sort of drug dealers everywhere. It is this sort of vision of an urban hell. And one ambitious young developer, Tom, I wonder if you can possibly guess who it is, sees this and he thinks he can turn it around.
地下室里有老鼠。很多房间被妓女占领了。超级恶棍正在地下室策划死亡射线。对。所有那种事情。到处都是毒贩。这是一种城市地狱的景象。而一位雄心勃勃的年轻开发商，汤姆，我想知道你是否能猜出他是谁，看到了这一点，他认为他可以扭转局面。
So he does a deal with the Defunct Railroad and with the Hyatt Hotel Corporation. And crucially, he needs a tax deal from Abraham Beam, from the outgoing mayor. As luck would have it, his father has precisely the contacts he needs. And Beam and the city give him a 40-year tax break to redevelop this hotel. So a few months after the blackout in the summer of 1978, well, a year after the blackout, I should say, he starts work on it. And it opens in September 1980, just weeks before the election of Ronald Reagan. I mean, the timing is unbelievable it opens as the hyatt grand central hotel and it's a new kind of hotel covered with
所以他与破产的铁路公司和凯悦酒店集团达成了一笔交易。至关重要的是，他需要亚伯拉罕·比姆，也就是即将离任的市长，给予税收优惠。幸运的是，他的父亲拥有他所需要的确切人脉。比姆和市政府给了他40年的减税政策来重新开发这家酒店。所以在大停电后的几个月，1978年夏天，好吧，大停电一年后，我应该说，他开始着手工作。它于1980年9月开业，就在罗纳德·里根当选前几周。我的意思是，时机令人难以置信，它作为凯悦大中央酒店开业，这是一种新型酒店，覆盖着
shimmering glass lots of bling very gold fittings absolutely massive atrium fountains so it's right on the cusp of the 1980s and it is this temple to what you mentioned, the Bonfire of the Vanities, 80s success. Now, one last thing, that tax break that I mentioned, that his dad got him, it cost the city of New York $410 million. That's the art of the deal, Dominic. That is the art of the deal. And Tom, the name of that young developer. Should he leave it hanging? Well, if you can't guess by now,
闪闪发光的玻璃，很多装饰，非常金色的配件，绝对巨大的中庭喷泉，所以它正处于80年代的边缘，它是你提到的那个东西的殿堂，《虚荣的篝火》，80年代的成功。现在，最后一件事，我提到的那个减税政策，他父亲为他争取到的，让纽约市损失了4.1亿美元。这就是交易的艺术，多米尼克。这就是交易的艺术。汤姆，那个年轻开发商的名字。我应该让他悬念吗？好吧，如果你现在还猜不到，
shall I put them out of their misery? It is, of course, Donald J. Trump. And on that bombshell, on that bombshell, we will bid farewell to Gotham City
我应该让他们脱离痛苦吗？他当然是唐纳德·J·特朗普。带着这个重磅炸弹，带着这个重磅炸弹，我们将告别哥谭市
in the 70s. On the cusp of the 80s. So, yeah, so I think that we should definitely do New York in the 80s. It's such a great subject. Yeah. I mean, as iconic as New York in the 70s, really. So, thank you, Dominic. Tom, why don't we go down to the Hyatt Grand Central and I'll buy you a martini.
在70年代。在80年代的边缘。所以，是的，所以我认为我们绝对应该做80年代的纽约。这是一个非常好的主题。是的。我的意思是，真的和70年代的纽约一样具有标志性。所以，谢谢你，多米尼克。汤姆，我们为什么不去凯悦大中央酒店，我请你喝马提尼。
That'd be fantastic. We'll head there. See you all very soon. Hope you've enjoyed it. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly
那太棒了。我们去那里。很快见到大家。希望你们喜欢。再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你们每周的
fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。